أشعر بالرضا حقًا اليوم حيث جلست
هناك في انتظار الحصول على لقاح فيروس كورونا الخاص بي
في ديسمبر الماضي
وأتذكر كيف
كانت هذه اللحظة عادية وغير عادية في
نفس الوقت
لم يكن فقط أن اللقاح لديه
القدرة على حمايتك
وأنا و  أنهي هذا الوباء ولكن
أيضًا إمكانية أن
تغير تكنولوجيا اللقاح الطب بشكل جذري
، كل هذا يبدأ مع هذه السلسلة الصغيرة من
المواد الجينية
المعروفة باسم messenger rna mrna
، وهي مصنوعة في أجسامنا طوال الوقت
وتوجه خلايانا لصنع
بروتينات
مختلفة وهي أيضًا العمود الفقري  من
لقاحات covid19 biontech و Moderna
في هذه الحالة لإرشاد أجسامنا
إلى
صنع بروتين سبايك المميز لفيروس كورونا ،
والذي بدوره يحفز نظام المناعة لدينا
على تكوين
أجسام مضادة لهذا البروتين المرتفع.
آلات صنع اللقاحات بمجرد حصولك
على التسلسل
يكون رد فعل من خطوة واحدة لجعل
rna رسم فايس  بدأ sman في التحقيق في
إمكانية التلاعب بمرنا
في منتصف العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين ، ثم كنا
نفكر
في استخدامه للقاحات من أجل العلاج
سريعًا إلى الأمام عقدين من الزمن وهذه
الأفكار حقيقة
واقعة وهم ينموون المعاصرون يختبرون الآن
هذه التقنية
للفيروس المضخم للخلايا الذي يعد الفيروس
المعدي الرائد  سبب العيوب الخلقية في
الولايات المتحدة ،
تستخدم شركة أخرى curvac
التكنولوجيا للقاح محتمل ضد داء الكلب
ويبدو أن الجميع يركزون على الإنفلونزا
حاليًا ، ويستغرق
تطوير لقاح الإنفلونزا حوالي ستة أشهر مما يعني
أنه يتعين على الباحثين إجراء تخمين مستنير
حول ما سيحدث  تكون سلالة الأنفلونزا الرئيسية
المنتشرة في الموسم المقبل
حتى قبل انتهاء موسم الأنفلونزا الحالي
، فقد يؤدي لقاح إنفلونزا mrna إلى تقصير هذا
الجدول الزمني إلى حوالي شهر
ما قد لا تعرفه هو أن الكثير من هذا
بدأ بقصة حب
فريق الزوج والزوجة من الأطباء أه
sahin
و oslam turechi تحدثت معهم
منذ أشهر عن
حقيقة فيروس كورونا مقابل الخيال  ما
هو المستقبل
الذي تفكر فيه الآن في تقنية mrna ، فهي
تقنية متعددة الاستخدامات
ويمكنك أيضًا استخدامها
للجمع بين
مستضدات متعددة على سبيل المثال السرطان ،
لذا تذكر فكرة تحويل
أجسامنا إلى آلات لصنع اللقاحات
بشكل جيد كما هي الآن في وقت مبكر  مراحل
القيام بذلك من
أجل السرطان ، ولكن بدلاً من
بروتين سبايك لفيروس كورونا ، يجدون
علامات خلوية لسرطان الفرد
ويقومون بشكل أساسي بتدريب جهاز المناعة
على
محاربته بشكل محدد للغاية وسريع جدًا ،
إنها خفة الحركة التي تعتمد عليها شركة فايزر
الآن لمحاربتها.  المتغيرات الجديدة المحتملة
للفيروس التاجي ،
هدفنا هو القيام بذلك في غضون ثلاثة أشهر لتكون
قادرًا على تطوير متغير جديد ، يمكنك
الحصول عليه من خلال الإنتاج
وتقديمه للمرضى
في عام حدث فيه الكثير من
الأخطاء ، ومن الجدير الاحتفال حقًا بالأشياء
التي سارت بشكل صحيح.
مليون جرعة تضخ من هنا أصبح
مايك ماكديرموت ، أحد شركات فايزر
، عاطفيًا بعض الشيء عندما طلبت
منه التفكير في اللحظة
التي كان والدي يعمل فيها لدى ناسا.
عملت في برنامج أبولو
وفي اليوم الذي شحنا فيه الجرعات
الأولى من هذا الموقع ، اندفع فوقي كما لو
كانت تلك هي اللحظة التي أطلق
فيها القمر لقطة للقمر لم نكن
محظوظين للغاية لمشاهدتها
بالمناسبة كجراح.  أنا أيضًا
خائف قليلاً من الإبر ولكن لكي
نختبر أنفسنا في الواقع ،
أبلغنا الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا ،
نعم ، هذا جيد ،
هذا جيد ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك في أي وقت تحصل فيه على
شكر كبير للسفر